one time I almost got kicked off Late
Late Show because I was on stilts as a
fellow circus man and they were like if
you fall off your stilts we're not using
this we're gonna kick you off the show
and then my wig fell off but then I'm
going I'm like this is my one chance to
be on stilts on television like how am I
not gonna fall what else am I gonna do
it's not that interesting to see someone
walk on stilts I've seen you do it tons
of times you've never seen me understood
without me falling exactly and that's
the only good part you know even though
in my mind going into that performance I
was like there is no way that I'm gonna
fall I don't want to jeopardize this
this is a big moment and then well
happening I was like I have to fall